i think it's reasonable to do one more
separable differential equation problem
so let's do it
let's see
the derivative
of y with respect to x is equal to
y cosine
of x
divided by 1 plus
2
y squared and they give us an initial
condition that y
of 0 is equal to 1. or when x is equal
to 0 y is equal to 1. and i know we did
a couple already but another way to
think about separable differential
equations is really all you're doing is
implicit differentiation in reverse or
another way to think about it is
whenever you took an implicit derivative
the the end product was a separable
differential equation and so you know
that's just a little just so
hopefully forms a little bit of a
connection but anyway let's just do this
we have to separate the y's from the x's
let's multiply both sides times one plus
two y squared
we get
one plus two y
squared
times
d y
d x is equal to y
cosine
of x we still haven't fully separated
the y's and the x's let's divide both
sides of this by y
and then let's see we get 1 over y
1 over y plus
2y squared divided by y that's just 2y
times d y
d x is equal to cosine of x
i can just multiply both sides by d x
1 over y
plus 2 y
times d y is equal to cosine of x
dx and now we can integrate both sides
let's integrate both sides
so what's the integral of one over y
with respect to y i know your gut
reaction is the natural log of y which
is correct but there's actually a
slightly broader function than that
whose derivative is actually 1 over y
and that's the natural log of the
absolute value of y
and this is just a slightly uh broader
function because
its domain
is it includes positive and negative
numbers it just excludes zero while
natural log of y only includes numbers
larger than zero so natural log of
absolute value of y is nice and it's
actually true that at all points other
than zero its derivative is one over y
so it's just a slightly broader function
so that's the anti-derivative of one
over y and we proved that or at least we
prove that the derivative of natural log
of y is 1 over y
plus what's the anti-derivative of 2y
with respect to y well it's y squared
is equal to i'll do the plus c on this
side what's the whose derivative is
cosine of x what's sine of x
sine of x
and then we could add the
plus
c
we can add that plus c there and what
was our initial condition y of 0 is
equal to 1. so when x is equal to 0 y is
equal to one
so when x is equal to zero y is equal to
one so ln of the absolute value of one
plus one squared is equal to sine
of zero plus c
the natural log of one e to the what
power is one well zero
plus one is the sine of zero is zero is
equal to c so we get c is equal to one
so the solution to this differential
equation
up here
is i don't even have to rewrite it we
figured out c is equal to one so we
could just scratch this out we could put
a one and the natural log of the
absolute value of y plus y squared is
equal to sine of x
plus 1. and actually if you were to
graph this you would see that
y never actually dips below or even hits
the x-axis so you could actually get rid
of that absolute value function there
but anyway that's just a little
technicality but this is the implicit
form of of the solution to this
differential equation that makes sense
because these separable differential
equations are really just implicit
derivatives backwards
and in general one thing
that's kind of fun about differential
equations but kind of not as satisfying
about differential equations is it
really is just a whole hodgepodge of
tools to solve different types of
equations there isn't just one tool or
one theory that will solve
all differential equations there are a
few that will solve a certain class of
differential equations but there's not
just one consistent way to solve all of
them and frank and even today there are
unsolved differential equations where
the only way that we know how to get
solutions is using a computer
numerically and and one day i'll do
videos on that and actually you'll
you'll find that
in most applications that's what you end
up doing anyway because most
differential equations you you encounter
in science or in
with any kind of science whether it's
economics or physics or or engineering
they often are unsolvable because
they're going to have you know
they might have a second or third
derivatives involved and they're going
to multiply i mean they're going to be
really complicated very hard to solve
analytically and you actually are going
to solve them numerically which which is
often much easier but anyway hopefully
at this point you have a pretty good
sense of separable equations there's
just implicit differentiation backwards
it's really nothing new
our next thing we'll learn is exact
differential equations and then we'll
we'll go off into more and more methods
and then hopefully by the end of this
playlist you'll have a nice tool kit of
all of the different ways to solve at
least the solvable differential
equations see in the next video